when was the last time you sat down and
watched some queen bees footage I hate
you
really oh god it's so embarrassing
no I don't go back and watch that no
what if we had some no are you joking no
it's here shut the oh my god so I've
always been told that I come off as
being very conceited and aggressive to
be stared at all the time
it really does get into line there are
days when I wake up and I'm like I wish
I looked ugly
[Music]
I really I can't man say hi wearing my
group of friends in high school again
following behind I like little duckling
can they go people would refer to us
here for one minute I have one minute
and I'm charming dream is perfect 11
years ago people 11 years ago I don't
think I'm gonna change a soup kitchen
Stassi Schroeder taking a cringe-worthy
trip down reality TV memory lane we're a
bunch of teenage girls who just like
became friends for like a good few years
because we were like traumatized by
being like recorded 24/7 literally
filmed 24/7 in a house with these girls
that was mortifying but I'm really good
at reality television yeah I always was
I guess yeah that feels it's very much
the vibe of the Stasi we met season 1 I
am the devil and don't you forget it the
Vanderpump rules star revisits more of
her past in her new book next level
basic why how to humor book instead of a
straight-up memoir do you really picture
me really like I'm gonna do a memoir I'm
I'm 30 years old I haven't really
experienced that much life I mean I've
always wanted to write but I never
really knew what I wanted to write about
and when I started my podcast like I
realized that like everyone who was
emailing me and they like always loved
the fact that I was just like owning the
fact that I'm a proud basic [ __ ] and
then like one day I was like oh my god
that's it like I am a basic [ __ ]
warrior that that'll be on my tombstone
well you won't learn many vpr secrets in
the so called a definitive a basic [ __ ]
handbook listen I want to keep my job
right sorry you will get to know more
about Stassi things that people didn't
know about me like one how I lost my
it was the cringy assinged to write and
like live through again but like I got
wasted at home and like did it by myself
and I just like really like how to laugh
and like it was almost like therapy I
mean that was really fun to just go back
and think about things that you know pre
Vanderpump rules that I hadn't thought
about in a while there are a lot of
stories that I now like I wake up in
like from like a dead sleep and I'm like
mother I should have put this in I
should have put this in and I'm just
like now compiling like a whole list
that I've just been like book number two
and putting this out there so that I can
like let all of those stories go I feel
like book number two will happen I have
an idea of what I want it to be
it's like Chelsea Handler left the seat
open for the humor comedy book that is
such a compliment wherever you're going
with this continue I can say now you can
sit there and continue on this train of
writing after book number one reason why
people should go pick up a copy of next
level basic because you want to laugh
and feel good about yourself I think
they will do that finally stop torturing
me with this Queen Bee tip another
clipping
[Music]